las imágenes no son muy diferentes a las
de 2015 ya en marzo en la antigua
aeropuerto berlinés de tegel fue
asignado para acoger a refugiados
ucranianos Pero a medida que se acerca
el invierno su capacidad está llegando a
la saturación por ello las autoridades
ordenaron la instalación de tiendas de
campaña en el asfalto acogerán a 400
personas más
entramos en estado de emergencia en
febrero y sabíamos desde el principio
que esta situación excepcional
continuaría este invierno
los ucranianos que tienen acceso al
estatuto de refugiado al llegar a la
Unión Europea son registrados y alojados
localmente a la espera de encontrar un
lugar en una residencia o en una casa
particular el Antiguo aeropuerto de
Berlín es actualmente el mayor centro de
acogida de Alemania y no está a punto de
cerrarse según la senadora encargada de
la integración el estado de Berlín
tendrá que crear 10.000 lugares más de
acogida de aquí a finales de año aunque
ya hemos creado muchas en los últimos
meses
pero el aumento de nuevas llegadas es
tan rápido que crear esta nueva
capacidad es una auténtica Carrera
contra el reloj
este año Alemania ya ha acogido a más
refugiados que en 2015 en plena crisis
migratoria y según las autoridades aún
no se ha alcanzado el pico en octubre se
tramitaron 1750 solicitudes de asilo en
este otro centro de llegada de Berlín
frente a sólo 850 en agosto la duración
media de la asistencia es ahora de 17
días sé que en este momento hay muchos
ucranianos y la prioridad la tienen los
ucranianos
[Música]
hacen lo que pueden Ya ven y todo es
gratis para que quejarse aquí sin duda
las autoridades han aprendido las
lecciones de la crisis migratoria de
2015 desde entonces se han construido
unos 30 edificios para alojar a
solicitantes de asilo sin embargo Aquí
también han vuelto los catres algunos
tienen que pasar aquí 14 días y en esta
habitación se ve que es muy difícil que
cuatro personas compartan este espacio
de 16 metros cuadrados
lo ve todos los días los solicitantes de
asilo procedentes de Siria Afganistán o
Irak son cada vez más numerosos el 99%
de los 27.000 cupos de Berlín ya están
asignados normalmente la gente llega
sobre todo en verano
pero la situación es tan catastrófica en
estos momentos en los centros de
alojamiento de algunos países
de la ruta de los balcanes que la gente
prefiere hacer las maletas y dirigirse
copa central en toda Alemania en los
municipios están construyendo muros para
hacer frente a estas llegadas aquí en la
epsic se utilizarán carpas con
calefacción a finales de noviembre
mientras que Andrés desea habilitado el
centro de convenciones pero el temor a
nuevas tensiones como en 2015 es
omnipresente
en octubre refugiados ucranianos fueron
agredidos en lightzig por manifestantes
de extrema derecha y los ataques a
centros de solicitantes de asilo han
aumentado desde principios de año en
bowsen al este del país un incendio
afectó a un hotel que iba a alojar a
migrantes desde entonces la ciudad ha
solicitado una excepción para dejar de
aceptar refugiados un cambio que divide
a los habitantes
sería una señal desastrosa para el resto
del país no podemos rechazar a los
inmigrantes con el pretexto de que
podría crear tensiones pero también
tiene que ver con costos y los tiempos
son Realmente difíciles en Alemania como
en todas partes
con 57.000 refugiados ucranianos y 15
mil solicitantes de asilo recibidos en
sajonia desde principios de año la
región ha alcanzado el punto de
saturación según el Ministerio del
interior Estatal pero en vez de esto es
manifestantes culpan a los políticos
locales de hacer el juego de la extrema
derecha denuncian el creciente número de
expulsiones y las condiciones de acogida
cada vez más difíciles para los
inmigrantes no ucranianos sin embargo
según el consejo de refugiados de la
región Alemania dispone de medios para
acoger a los inmigrantes en buenas
condiciones los políticos deben ser
conscientes De que al sembrar el pánico
en realidad están alimentando las
campañas de desprestigio de la extrema
derecha Nos gustaría ver más solidaridad
con los exiliados en la sociedad y en la
política Esto es lo que evitaría una
situación similar a 2015 la gestión de
la crisis migratoria contribuyó a la
auge de la extrema derecha en Alemania
un escenario que las autoridades quieren
evitar esta vez el gobierno va a
desbloquear 1500 millones de euros de
aquí a finales de año para ayudar a los
municipios a acoger refugiados